(soft music)
I was giving a speech in St. Louis.
And after the speech I was sitting and signing books
and I went unconscious.
The paramedics put me on the gurney
and that was the first time I went flatline.
And over the next 90 minutes, I flatlined nine times.
(upbeat music)
I had to look at my life and say, is this the life I want?
I was having I guess a midlife crisis.
(upbeat music)
But it was ultimately the thing that helped me
to say, get outta jail free Chip (chuckles).
You don't have to die.
And I can start rewriting the script
of how I wanna live my life.
Hey, everybody, welcome to the podcast.
Today's topic revolves around how to rethink aging.
And to think of aging, not as something to be feared,
but rather as something aspirational, an opportunity.
An opportunity to share all that accrued wisdom,
to channel it into a second act,
and leverage it to deepen and make more meaningful
your connection with life, your connection with others,
and of course your connection with self.
My guest for this odyssey is my new friend Chip Conley.
Chip is a hotelier and hospitality maverick,
as well as the former strategic advisor
and global head of hospitality for Airbnb.
Where he was instrumental in guiding the founders
of what was then just a startup,
into the global hospitality brand it is today.
Today Chip is an in-demand public speaker,
is a multiple TED talker,
a New York times bestselling author.
He sits on the board of Burning Man
and he's the founder of Modern Elder Academy.
The first midlife wisdom school
dedicated to transforming aging.
And I would say that,
although this conversation is tailored
towards those in or approaching middle age,
honestly I think it's for anyone and everyone,
especially those who are looking to weave
a little bit more meaning and a little bit more fulfillment
into your professional life.
Particularly those who have pursued a certain career track
for some time and are now contemplating new possibilities.
We discuss overcoming our fear of aging.
We talk about navigating midlife transitions,
what it means to be a modern elder
and how to receive and give mentorship.
We also talk about mindset.
We talk about identity.
We talk about getting clear on what is absolutely essential
to being fulfilled and the re-imagination
of both continuing education and communal living.
Chip is just a wonderful man.
He's a beautiful spirit.
This conversation I think will leave you pondering
your contribution to life just a little bit more deeply.
And I think we'll put a smile on your face along the way.
So please hit that subscribe button if you haven't already.
And here we go, this is me and Chip Conley.
Well, it's good to see you.
It's been a couple weeks-
Thank you.
Since we met down in Miami.
I haven't shaved since,
I'm trying to cultivate my modern elder look.
Your modern elder like-
My modern elder aesthetic.
You're looking wise.
And I can't wait to dig into all of this with you today.
And I was reflecting as I was driving in,
wrapping my head around how to approach this with you.
And top of mind is a conversation that I had just
a couple days ago.
We had this guy, Mike Fremont in here who's 100 years old.
Like he turned 100 this year.
Wow.
And he set
like the world record for the marathon at age 90.
He holds like all kinds of age group running records
and he kind of kicked it off by saying,
"I'm having the best time of my life.
"Like, I'm happiest now than I've ever been."
And it's like he's a little hard of hearing
and he is 100 years old.
But to hear him say oh yeah, life is really great right now,
is something counterintuitive.
But also like right in the sweet spot of your lane
and the things that you're passionate about.
What's fascinating is there's a societal narrative
on aging, and then there's a personal narrative.
The societal narrative is if you can survive
your midlife crisis around 45 or 50,
on the other side of that,
you have disease and decrepitude and then you die.
And the reality is the personal narrative on people's aging
is very different than that.
And there's something called the U-curve of happiness.
It's gotten a lot of social science research attention.
And the idea of it is once you hit around 47.2,
although your mileage may vary,
with each passing decade after that,
you get happier and happier.
So you're happier in your 50s than your 40s,
60s than 50s, 70s than 60s.
And you start to see some leveling out
and a decline in happiness,
around the last two or three years of your life.
So if you're living to 100
and maybe who knows how long he'll live.
He's probably still on the stride going up.
Yeah.
But what's so strange is the gap
between the personal narrative,
which is actually people do get happier as after age 50.
And the societal narrative, which you're all downhill
after about age 40.
But I would suspect that happiness quotient
would calibrate to you still finding purpose and meaning
in however you're spending your time.
Like the way we think about aging is so unhealthy.
It's like this black hole
and I know you've talked about this,
there's childhood, there's adulthood.
And then what?
Like what happens for 40 or 50 years?
Like we don't really talk about it.
You dubbed it elderhood,
but short of housing people in these horrible
sort of assisted living situations,
we haven't really created
any kind of modern forward-thinking
kind of programming around like,
how to get the most out of these many decades later in life.
If you're gonna live 'til 90,
which is very likely for a lot of us.
My parents are 84.
Neither one of them has been a huge athlete
and they're on a six week vacation right now, at age 84.
So if you live 'til 90,
and you're 54 which is a little bit younger than you.
You're halfway through your adult life.
If you start counting at age 18.
And we don't think about life that way.
We very much underestimate how much adult life
we have ahead of us.
We also overestimate how long we're gonna be an invalid.
And there's something called compressed morbidity
in the medical field.
It means that in essence the time of your life,
when you're on the verge of death is a much shorter period
on average than it used to be.
So you've got what Mary Catherine Bateson would call,
is she calls it the midlife atrium.
She says that having additional life,
having additional years...
Because longevity in the year 1900 was 47 on average.
And by the year 2000, it was 77.
She says, all of those additional years
are not like having extra bedrooms
in the backyard of your house.
Like you're old longer.
Now she says it's like having a midlife atrium.
And the midlife atrium means there's light and air,
and additional space happening in the middle of your life.
So you're in midlife longer.
And yet we have very little in the way of society,
resources, tools,
or even thinking around what midlife is supposed to be.
Yeah.
But historically we were much better at this.
Any kind of indigenous culture has a reverence
and a respect for their elders
that we somehow forgot as we modernize.
Well, is the Western society.
I mean it still exists in indigenous societies.
It still exists a little bit in Asia and Latin America.
But quite frankly, everywhere in the world
if you had a choice between going to grandpa or Google
to go get your information, you go to Google.
And I think that has meant that we have lost
that opportunity to tap into the wisdom of the elders.
But I don't think we're gonna go back to that.
I don't think we're in an era
where it's gonna be all about reverence of the elders again.
I think it's about relevance.
So how do we help our elders...
And elders, if you could be an elder at 40, if you are...
I mean, Terry Cruz, who you had on the show recently
he's an elder and he's in his 50s.
That he was an elder when he was in his 40s
amongst some of the people he was hanging around.
And so how do we create a relationship
between the young and the old
in such a way that they can learn from each other.
Yeah.
My wife's father, he passed away a couple years ago at 91.
But he was a civil engineer in Alaska, in Anchorage
and was instrumental in the construction
of a lot of the downtown buildings and institutions,
including like their fabulous art museum.
And he worked with...
A lot of the construction entities
were run by Native American people
who have that reverence and respect.
And even though he was like losing his sight
and all of these things,
they kept like hiring him for all of these jobs
up until like the very end of his life.
Like he was making more money
and more kind of like meaningfully employed
than he had been throughout his career.
Which speaks to relevance and him continuing to find meaning
in his life.
And yes, we're not going back to that.
But I think this idea of relevance is so important
as exemplified through your experience with Airbnb.
So maybe we can kind of step back a little bit.
Sure.
And contextualize this with your story.
So my story is, I grew up in Southern California,
went up to Northern California for college.
We both went to Stanford.
You swam, I played water polo-
Water polo player.
We were a couple years separated.
Yes.
But we have some common friends from that era.
We do.
And we used to swim in the same pool.
And I went to business school there.
And couple years outta that business school
started a boutique hotel company.
You went straight to Stanford Business-
I went (indistinct).
That would rarely happen.
It really doesn't.
I was 23 when I graduated from Stanford Business School,
very unusual.
Seth Goden and I were the two youngest people in our class.
I heard when you were on Tim Ferris's podcast,
talking about the kind of mastermind group
that you formed with him,
and you guys would get together
and talk about business ideas.
And you ended up co-writing a book with Seth-
I did.
In business school.
I did and we're deep close friends
because we were both sort of weirdos in business school.
So couple years out of business school,
I started a boutique hotel company called Joie de Vivre.
Meaning joy of life.
And created 52 boutique hotels around California.
And then I sold...
I mean, come back to that possibly.
I sold it partly because my life was falling apart.
We'll come back to that.
Let's go forward and say,
okay, I created some space in my life.
And that's when I was called by Brian Chesky,
the co-founder and CEO of Airbnb.
And I quite frankly,
10 years ago didn't know what Airbnb was.
I was this hotelier
who was about to get disrupted by Airbnb.
And I didn't really know what this was.
And he asked if I could be his in-house mentor
and help this little tech startup
become a global hospitality brand.
And so I joined and quickly became known as the modern elder
at Airbnb (chuckles).
Which was not exactly the title I was looking for.
Yeah.
At age what?
You were 52.
I was 52.
Brian was 31, average age in the company was 26.
So do the math.
And they called me the modern elder
partly because they said,
Joe Gabby, one of the other co-founders said,
"Chip, you're as curious as you are wise."
And I was like,
oh, well, I don't love the title modern elder.
But if a modern elder is someone
who's as curious as they are wise,
and they know how to have the right alchemy of curiosity
and wisdom in their life.
That describes me pretty well.
Sure.
And I want to...
Sorry to interrupt,
but I do want to put a finer point
on how you were able to kind of cultivate that curiosity
in the wake of a successful exit from your company.
Maybe we can come back to that.
'Cause I think it is related to one other thing
that you want to talk about.
Yeah.
I'll come back to that.
And I'll just tell a little bit of that Airbnb story now.
Is that sounds good.
Yeah.
So yes, I joined this place.
I'd never been in a tech company before.
I thought they wanted me for my knowledge
of the hospitality industry.
I mean, but frankly, it didn't really matter
how many rooms made (indistinct) an eight hours shift
in the Airbnb host world.
So within, actually it was the third day on the job,
I was in a meeting where Brian had said,
"Listen, go spend a lot of time with the engineers.
"You've never been in a tech company before.
"Start learning the lingo."
And so I thought I was supposed to be the mentor,
but at the end of an hour meeting with a bunch of engineers,
I knew I was the intern.
I was like Robert de Niro,
in the movie with Anne Hathaway.
But he came in as the intern and he became the mentor.
I actually came in as the mentor and now I'm the intern.
And what I realized is that,
I didn't understand the language,
but that didn't mean I couldn't learn it.
When I say the language, I meant like in that meeting,
someone turned to me,
the guy writing the meeting a 25-year-old guy turns to me
and says, "Chip, if you ship a feature and no one used it,
"did it really ship?"
And I was like, I have no idea what you're talking about.
Shipping a feature I've never worked in a tech company.
So I had to acknowledge that I was not the smartest person
in the room.
I might have been the most curious person
in the room at times and maybe the wisest,
but I had to be open to learning.
And my father said to me,
"Chip, how could you turn your fear into curiosity?"
And that was a really great reframe for me.
Because I guess at 52 having run a company for 24 years,
taking it from one person to 3,500 people.
There was a part of me that in my early to mid 50s,
I was thinking, oh, what if my last career step
is a big mistake and I'm just a huge failure here?
So I think part of what really helped,
I was willing to be humble
and vulnerable about what I didn't know.
And often I was asking questions that helped the company
to see their blind spots or see our blind spots.
And I think it was that process
that helped me to see that, gosh,
more tech companies could use a modern elder.
I just watched, we crashed.
Right.
And of course then there's "Super Pumped."
And then there's the Inventor with Elizabeth Holmes.
I mean, thank god, there's no Airbnb movie like that.
This mini series,
drama mini series of like these crash and burn tales.
But if you look at it, none of those companies
really had a modern elder.
Well it's interesting
'cause you wrote a blog post about this,
on your Wisdom Well blog.
Yeah.
I watched all those founder series.
Like I'm fascinated by them and they vary in quality.
But the recurring theme is,
ego gets the best of these people
when it spirals outta control.
But in the example of "Super Pumped,"
which is about Travis Kanak and Uber,
there actually was a modern elder in that context.
They had Bill Gurley, who is the benchmark VC.
Was sort of the stand-in for the modern elder,
but he's butting up against an ego that is not having it.
And that of course, sows the seeds for the downfall
of his career.
Yeah and the big difference for him...
And you had Bruce Dunlevy for WeWork,
who I went to business school with same class as me.
But investors don't have time to be 24 hours a day
in-house at the company.
So Bill or Bruce will come to a meeting
and say, "Okay, what's going on?"
But then they go back and they look at the rest
of their portfolio.
And ultimately Bill got more involved in the business,
but quite frankly, he could see what happens in a meeting.
And of course you'd see some signs of serious hubris.
And partly that's because Silicon Valley wants hubris.
It's funny, there's an element of like Silicon Valley
wants the confident, "Super Pumped" CEO founder.
And then they want them to miraculously move
from hubris to humility.
Right-
As a leader.
It's the package.
Like if you want the guy who has the massive vision
and the audacity to not only dream big, but execute on that,
you're gonna get the other side of it.
You are, and this is why...
Brian Chesky, let's talk about him for a moment.
When Brian approached me and said,
"I want you to come in-house and full time at Airbnb,
"and be my mentor,
"but also be the head of global hospitality and strategy,
"and a bunch of other things,"
I had to look at him and say,
okay, this guy, I'm 52, he's 31.
I'm gonna report to him, but I'm gonna be his mentor.
That's gonna be sort of odd.
What's gonna be like to report to my mentee.
And I had to have a level of confidence
that he wanted to learn.
And he had the hubris to go out and raise money,
but he had the humility to build a culture
and a leadership team.
And to maybe even take some direction occasionally from me.
Yeah.
And so I think that was the key.
And it's rare.
It is rare.
That's why's-
And hats off to him-
They're still the founders and it's functional.
It's amazing.
I mean we have three founders at Airbnb,
it's over $100 billion company now.
It's by far the most valuable hospitality company
in the world.
And the three founders are still very actively involved.
That's never happened before.
There's never been a company that has had that.
And I'm proud of...
I mean, I made all kinds of mistakes while I was there
and the company would've done well without me.
And yet I am very proud that the three of those founders
are still working together as they are.
Because I think the glue that needed to happen
amongst the three,
was partly between me and a couple other people
who helped them to feel that sense
of what each of them offered to the company
and to each other.
What's an example of some of the wisdom
that you were able to impart and also the receptivity
of Chesky and his team to what you had to offer.
Sometimes it was as simple as...
I mean, some of it was just little mechanical things.
Because one of the things you get better at,
as you get older is you've had the pattern recognition
in your life to see what worked and what didn't.
And so some of it was simple stuff
like Brian who went into that meeting
trying to sell the leadership team on something.
And you knew there were two people in that meeting
on the team who were gonna probably be critics of it.
What would've been great
is if you had spent some one-on-one time
with each or both of them before the meeting,
so they could actually air some of their concerns
instead of feeling like
they had to actually air it amongst everybody else.
Because then you could have adapted the plan a little bit.
So that's a simple thing.
Or another simple thing would be like at Thanksgiving,
we had all been running just crazy
70, 80, 90-hour weeks flying everywhere,
we're a global company.
And the leadership team's families, weren't seeing us.
And so it was Thanksgiving, and I said to Brian,
what if you sent just a thank you note,
maybe a bottle of wine or some flowers to the spouses
and family members of all the leadership team?
And just say, "This Thanksgiving,
"I just wanna say thanks to you."
Because what's happening behind the scenes, Brian is...
Brian he wasn't married, he didn't have kids.
But he didn't realize that.
Yeah.
Others did.
And behind the scenes, there's this person,
the spouse saying, "I don't want you to work this much."
And what we needed to really do is respect that.
So those are a couple simple ideas.
But WeWork...
I mean, Adam Newman wanted to do
a major strategic partnership with Airbnb.
And Brian was sort of had some cognitive dissonance on it.
He could see some of the value of it at one time.
But I said, Brian this guy is a messiah.
You've seen him act that way.
How are you gonna create a logical business relationship
with someone who believes they're the Messiah?
I would say that a lot of my wisdom
related to emotional intelligence.
How do you develop emotional intelligence as a leader
when you've had no background in being a leader?
Yeah.
Why do you think that Brian singled you out for this role?
Like what...
I mean, you have this robust history of being a mentor
that started actually quite early in your life
and in your career.
But why do you think he had the foresight to see the need
for a mentor
and what was it about you that he found attractive?
So, Brian is got the most voracious appetite
for learning that I've ever met in my life.
And so like when Airbnb in 2011 had this...
Someone like totally trashed an apartment,
he decided to go to the former head of the CIA.
to learn about safety and security
and how he could actually make the Airbnb platform safer.
And so he had also had been talking
to a guy named John Donahoe.
So John's a friend of mine.
And he and I were in YPO together.
And we were in the same form.
John's the CEO of Nike now.
But back then, John was about 10 years ago, the eBay CEO.
And so Brian, knowing that eBay had some similarities
to Airbnb in terms of there was a two-sided marketplace,
he was working with John as a mentor part-time.
And so John, I think said to Brian,
"You should talk to Chip."
And Brian was like, well, tell me more about Chip.
And so as Brian learned more, Brian said,
"Oh man, I wanna learn from him."
But I think what Brian initially was looking for
was someone who had the knowledge
of the hospitality and travel industry.
Because when I joined the company,
no one in the company had that background at all.
But I think what he learned over time was he said,
"I hired you for your knowledge,
"but what I've really gotten was your wisdom.
"And it's your wisdom of understanding people
"and leadership and strategy."
So I think one of the things we get better at
as we get older is holistic thinking.
Arthur Brooks talks about this in his new book,
"From Strength to Strength."
Yeah.
He's coming in soon.
Oh, is he?
He's scheduled yeah.
Oh man, we are buddies.
Yeah.
You guys are like every time in researching like articles
and stuff like that, it's like your name
and his name always kind of are appearing in the same-
I love...
You know, he's so...
He's like speaking of "Super Pumped."
I mean, this is a guy who's adrenalized,
and I really enjoy sometimes sparring with him,
intellectual jousting.
But in his book "From Strength to Strength,"
he talks about going from fluid intelligence,
to crystallized intelligence.
Crystallized intelligence is...
Fluid intelligence is very focused logical.
And it's about actually innovating
within a certain linear course.
But fluid I'm sorry.
Crystallized intelligence is when you are looking at things
more holistically.
Because one of the things that's interesting about our brain
is as we age,
we actually move from being very focused in the brain
to actually having four wheel drive of the brain.
We actually move much more lyrically and logically
from one side, the right side to the left side.
Which is great.
Because what it means is that we can actually look
systemically and holistically
at things and connect the dots.
It makes sense because you've accumulated
so many experiences over the course of your life.
You get to a point where you're able to synthesize
all of that information.
And I feel like just at 55 now,
like an ability to kind of see things
a little bit more clearly than I could-
Yeah, I think...
And whether it's wisdom or intuition, pattern recognition,
you get to a place where
the right answer just sort of pops up.
And it's not because you've done some mathematical theory
to get there.
It's actually coming from your lived experience.
I like to think of wisdom as metabolized experience
which leads to distilled compassion.
And so in both cases the metabolized of experience,
how am I digesting my experience,
leads to understanding yourself more, the world more,
and then being able to have some level of compassion.
'Cause I think wisdom without compassion
is just doing something for yourself.
One of the things I did early on, Rich,
when I was 28 years old.
So I started my boutique hotel company when I was 26.
At 28, I realized I was clueless.
I knew I was clueless at 26 too.
'Cause I bought a motel in San Francisco.
In a bad neighborhood.
It was a pay by the hour motel.
Which if you know what that means,
it means it was very popular at lunchtime (chuckles).
People would come and have their little affair at lunchtime
and then go home or go back to the office.
And so at age 28, two years into it,
I realized like, I don't know if this business is gonna work
and we had the San Francisco Loma Prieta or earthquake.
And I was like, oh my god, we have no business now.
So I started doing something that actually,
I would recommend everybody do.
I mean, it's just simple about metabolizing experience.
Every weekend I would sit down with a diary.
Somebody had given it to me as a diary.
I didn't use it as a diary.
I used it as a place to understand my wisdom.
And so I called it my wisdom book.
And each weekend I would create like three, four,
maybe eight different bullet points
of what I'd learned that week.
And often the learning was painful.
It was things like, oh man.
Linda (indistinct) wanted to take over our whole hotel,
but I took a day to get back to her travel agent
and they booked something else.
So it's like, okay.
Simple lesson, which is like, okay if the travel agent-
Move quickly.
Yeah move quickly.
I mean don't waste time.
And so long story short is every weekend for over 30 years,
I sat down and wrote in one of 10 wisdom books,
and now Google docs, with what I learned that week.
And the value in doing this is, it actually allows you
to start to metabolize your experience.
You could do this for a team.
You could say once a quarter, we as a leadership team
are gonna do a vulnerable kind of experience where we said,
what was my biggest lesson this quarter?
And then let each person speak up about what was the lesson?
What did they learn from it
and how they're gonna use it moving forward?
Because that's a way we start
to metabolize experience into wisdom.
Yeah, that's amazing.
So that's a practice that you still to this day do?
I still do, yeah.
I don't do it every week.
So let me be clear because I wanna be fully honest.
I do it once a month now.
I don't do it every weekend anymore.
Okay.
But I did it every weekend for about 30 years.
Wow.
It conjures in my mind sort of a hybrid
between a very directed journaling exercise
where you're going in.
You're not just like doing morning pages
where you're vomiting out whatever.
You're very intentional
about what it is that you're focused on writing about
matched with a practice that,
you know I've been in recovery for a long time.
This is sort of like a daily thing to do an inventory.
To like check yourself a little bit.
Like, where am I going wrong?
How did I contribute to that thing not going well,
et cetera.
Which leads to a deeper level of self awareness.
Yeah, I wish someone had told me this.
You know, it's such a simple practice,
but such a profound one in the sense
of our life is meant to be examined,
but not examined as if we did something wrong.
Maybe we made a mistake,
but the lesson from that mistake
actually makes us smarter for the future
or wiser for the future.
And so I recommend it for most of the people
that I work with
and there's about six CEOs I mentor today just as friends.
I mean, I don't do it for a living.
And I tell them it's really simple.
But like so many things that are simple, it's a practice.
Yeah.
And you have to do it,
otherwise it won't meaning to anything.
We should mention that the pay by hour hotel,
fleabag motel in the Tenderloin district of San Francisco
became the Phoenix.
I've stayed there many times,
such an epic hotel and such a diverse dynamic neighborhood.
I was in San Francisco this past weekend.
I did not stay at the Phoenix.
I ended up staying at the Proper hotel.
Oh yeah.
Which is on the edge of the Tenderloin.
The Tenderloin has really not got much better.
(both laugh)
You know.
I bought this place-
Since I live in San Francisco.
It's 35 years ago and it's actually worse
than it was 35 years ago.
It's one of the few neighborhoods in San Francisco
that hasn't gentrified.
Yeah, it's a CD neighborhood and it's...
But there's a lot.
It is CD and there's a lot of rich history there.
Sure.
And a lot of really interesting cultural things.
I was on the board of Glide Memorial Church,
Cecil Williams Church in the tenure line for many years.
And just beautiful, there's a lot of humanity there.
It's sort of like going to India.
Yeah.
(Chip laughs)
But the Phoenix became known
as like the rock and roll hotel.
Like all the bands stayed there,
like just legends of music over the years.
Which is pretty cool.
Like, was that an intention going into it
or did that grow out of (indistinct) factor-
I was a 26 year old
who said I wanna get into the boutique hotel business
because it seems as if it's about to take off.
So Ian Schrager and Bill Kimpton were
the first two U.S. boutique hoteliers.
I was the one right after them.
And I was like, they're successful,
I wanna be successful too.
And so I said, each time we would create a hotel,
let's imagine a magazine that defines the hotel.
And because magazines and boutique hotels
have something in common.
They're niche-oriented and lifestyle oriented.
So that first hotel of Phoenix
was based upon Rolling Stone magazine.
And we came up with five adjectives
that defined Rolling Stone.
Funky, irreverent, adventurous, cool, and young at heart.
And everything we did in creating that first hotel
had to come back to those five adjectives.
And then miraculously,
what we found was the people who fell in love with the hotel
were people who would use those five adjectives
to describe themselves on a good day.
So it was like, you are where you sleep.
So that's what a boutique hotel is.
It's sort of like an identity refreshment.
It's aspirational.
And so every hotel...
Yeah, so the first hotel was all about rock and roll bands
because at 26, like, oh yeah,
I'd love to have Nirvana and Pearl Jam,
and Red Hot Chili Peppers staying here all at the same time
on their way to becoming famous bands.
And that happened a lot,
those three bands actually toured a lot together.
So that's how it started.
And then all 52 of the boutique hotels
were based upon different magazines in different-
So each one had its own magazine?
It did, or sometimes a mixture of two.
Like there's a hotel of Italian in San Francisco.
Yeah.
Closed-
Stayed there too.
in the pandemic.
So that was dwell meets real simple.
So modern, urban, fresh, natural, and nurturing.
And so it was sweet in some ways
I was like an armchair psychologist (laughs).
By saying,
okay, what are some of the personalities out there,
who would like to see a hotel that's there perfect habitat.
Yeah, well, creativity is central to this,
a knack for marketing.
Some foresight about where this industry was headed.
It's hard to imagine at this point
a world without boutique hotels.
Yeah.
Like no young person is staying at a Hyatt or a Hilton.
Well, they're actually staying in Airbnb.
Well, yeah exactly.
(Chip laughs)
Like, yeah, right-
Actually boutique hotels were sort of a precursor
for Airbnb.
Sure.
Yeah of course, like a bespoke environment.
And just having stayed at the Proper,
like that chain and many others.
Owes its legacy to this kind of legwork
that you did many years ago.
Yeah, if you go into almost
any full service Hyatt or Hilton today,
they are trying to be like a boutique hotel.
The bar is sort of central.
The music is definitely not the music of 20 years ago.
The design is very different than it used to be.
So I think what the chains realized
and then ultimately they bought many of the boutique hotels.
My company is part of Hyatt,
Kimpton is part of Intercontinental.
Yeah (indistinct) of that.
Yeah, Marriott, Hyatt, Ian Schrager like, okay, there we go.
The bottom line is the big hotel change realized
that they needed to get hip
because the customer wanted more experience.
They didn't just want a boring, predictable experience.
(dramatic music)
Prophets walk among us.
As a writer and podcaster for nearly 10 years,
I've become more convinced than ever
that our world is populated by scores
of beautiful and brilliant people
who have amazing stories to share.
Those that we don't know who can teach us something new
and leave us all the better for the experience
of their sharing.
And so I've dedicated my career to tracking down
the most compelling prophets on the planet.
Going deep with each of them on my podcast
to elucidate the best of what they have to offer,
and to sharing the insights gleaned for the benefit of all.
But the podcast is not the only medium
by which to share their stories.
Which is why I'm proud to announce
the release of my new book, "Voicing Change Volume II."
More than mere words on paper,
"Voicing Change" is a physical manifestation of the magic,
inspiration, and timeless wisdom that transpires
each week on the Rich Roll podcast.
The first edition of "Voicing Change,"
was a beautifully rendered book worthy of display
on any coffee table.
And volume two follows in that tradition
by showcasing even more of my favorite conversations
in an elegant publication,
replete with interview excerpts, essays,
and stunning photography.
Making bur exquisite companion to the first volume
or a satisfying standalone work.
Picking up this book allows you to revisit the wisdom
of your favorite everyday prophets,
and physically interact with the life changing ideas
contained with them.
"Voicing Change Volume II," available now
while supplies last for a limited time.
Order your copy today only at richroll.com
Back to this idea of creativity.
It's interesting that out of business school,
your initial kind of career path was commercial real estate,
not exactly known for creative inspiration, right?
Just buying office space and leasing it, et cetera.
So how did you reconcile that creative spark
that I'm sure you had some self-awareness around,
and maybe a latent desire to be an entrepreneur
with being in that track
and then ultimately getting to the point
where you were capable of manifesting it.
So it's funny between my first
and second year of business school,
I worked in New York
for Morgan Stanley's real estate division.
It's so hard to just visualizing you (laughs).
I know.
But sort of classic,
like you're a business school student.
I mean, I was 22 between my first and second year
of business school.
The fact I was wearing suspenders smoking cigars,
and making deals as a Morgan Stanley real estate guy,
was sort of beyond me.
And they loved me and that gave me some great job offers
after business school.
But I just knew...
I think the question I had in my mind was,
what do I want to be when I grow up?
And what's gonna take me there?
Because actually the amount of money
they were throwing at me,
and the amount of prestige they were gonna give me,
they even knew that I wanted to be maybe back
in the West Coast sometimes soon.
So they're gonna like bring me to New York for a year
and then help run and open the office in LA,
the real estate office there.
I was like, you don't do this for a 22 or 23-year-old.
But I turned it down.
I turned down all the other job offers.
I took a job out of business school for $2,000 a month.
$24,000 a year, which was crazy.
I mean the average salary out of business school
at that point was about 85 to $90,000 a year.
But I took it because it was working for a creative...
What I thought was a creative
real estate development company that was...
Basically redeveloping what was called showplace square,
which was south of market.
And I just thought, you know what, I'm gonna go work there.
And the guy who ran the show and founded it,
said you could become a partner within a year.
And so I went to work there, but it wasn't creative enough.
I mean, I thought I chose creativity over money
and even the creative real estate development thing
I went to do wasn't creative enough for me.
So that's when I get to know again Bill Graham.
Bill Graham, the concert promoter.
Sure.
So Bill Graham was building shoreline and amphitheater
down in Mountain View on the peninsula, in the Bay Area.
And our CEO founder wanted me to do a deal
with Bill Graham (laughs).
So we were gonna be his partner on shoreline.
After that theater, I was like, okay, well, good luck.
I mean, Graham's got the money, he knows how to develop it.
What's our part in this thing.
So ultimately there was no deal to be made.
But Bill Graham pulled me aside,
he said, "I like you sonny."
He says...
At this point I was 25.
"I like your head spot.
"I like you're mensch.
"You know what you really need to do?
"Is you really need to create a hotel in San Francisco
"for the rock and roll bands."
Wow.
Because I have people coming to the war field
and the Fillmore and they're coming
to Great American Musical Hall
and the only place they go is an old place
called the Miyako, that was in Japantown,
which ultimately became the Hotel Kabuki,
which is Joie de Vivre hotel.
And they said there's no great place for them to stay.
And that's when the light bulb wheels
started to turn over my head.
And I was like, okay, maybe that's what I should do.
So I went to the head founder of our firm and I said,
I have a really creative idea for you.
And I told him what Bill Graham said to me
and he was like,
"Dude, we're not gonna get in the hotel business.
"Like, we'll lose our shirts.
"It's a terrible business."
Yeah, that's the thing with hotels.
Like if you wanna lose a ton of money, get into hotels.
Yeah, exactly.
Same with restaurants it's a sort of...
But I just said, you know what, I'm gonna go do it.
And so I started this company
on my 26th birthday and and bought the motel
on a 40-year land lease for $800,000.
Can you imagine buying a 44-room property
on an acre of land in San Francisco for $800,000.
You can't buy a condo for $800,000 in San Francisco,
A garage.
And that's what I bought.
And here we are 36 years later,
and I still own the Phoenix.
Although we only have about two and a half,
three years left on the land leases.
So how did you...
That story aside, like how did you transcend
that kind of conventional wisdom around hotels
are the way to lose money.
I'm thinking a scene in one of the "Ocean's 11" movies
where Brad Pitt, like it appears
that he bought the standard hotel on sunset.
Yes.
And he's like hemorrhaging all the money
that he had stolen in the earlier movie.
And everyone's making fun of him.
That's so funny.
That particular property before it was bought
by Andre Balazs and made it into the standard.
I had it in escrow.
But it was an old Jewish convalescent home.
And I'll never forget.
So this is now we're getting in some good stories.
Yes.
I walked through it after we were in escrow,
and this older Jewish woman came up to me
and pulled on my shirt sleeve.
And she says,
"Are you the guy who's gonna be actually buying this
"and throwing us out?"
Oh no!
And I just had this crisis of conscience and I said,
"Not gonna do that."
We'll let Brad Pitt do it.
We'll let Brad Pitt do exactly.
I think what made us different,
and the reason we succeeded is we got clear
that the reason a person chooses a boutique hotel
is because there's an aspirational lifestyle piece to it.
Now, Ian Schrager, who was really one of the first
he and Bill Kimp really were the two first
boutique hoteliers.
They had different perspectives.
So Schrager's perspective was it's all about being cool,
and maybe even narcissistic.
And so all of his hotels were about getting behind
the velvet rope.
Sure.
And Kimptons was much more sort of home spun European,
more like an in kind of experience,
where you have a good restaurant there, and a wine hour.
But they sort of kept playing the same game
over and over again.
And my point of view was like, geez,
there's so many different kinds of personalities out there.
Let's have this very schizophrenic company
where we have 52 different hotels
with all kinds of different personalities
that we're actually serving.
And so that's how-
Right.
But that's riskier because some of those aren't gonna work.
It's very riskier.
It's riskier and in some ways it's stupid
because we were like a branding agency.
Every single time we were creating a new hotel,
it was a new brand, a new market we were going after.
But it was very creative.
It was so much fun to create a hotel based upon Vanity Fair
meets Outside Magazine.
Which was a place called Costanoa, a luxury campground.
And so I loved it until I hated it.
So can I talk about that story now?
Yeah, let's talk about that.
Oh, (indistinct) Rich.
I was so, oh man.
So first of all, let's go back to, I was 26.
So one of the things we haven't talked about yet is,
so I played water polo at Stanford.
I was in a fraternity at Stanford.
I was Steven Townson Conley junior.
My dad was Stevens senior.
My dad was a Marine captain in the reserves.
I went to the same high school as my dad.
My dad was my baseball coach.
I was the star pitcher.
My dad was the Scoutmaster and an Eagle Scout.
And I was an Eagle Scout as well.
I went to the same high school as my dad,
played water polo and swim like my dad.
Then went to Stanford University, like my dad.
That's heavy.
Got a girlfriend-
That's a lot (laughs).
Got a girlfriend in freshman year of college,
just like my dad did, who ultimately became my mom.
I really (indistinct) telling your truths.
Exactly.
So I was like, oh my gosh.
So I was on this path.
Now I did join a different fraternity than my dad did.
And I did play water polo-
You were a fight?
I was fighter.
Yeah, that's where all the water polo players-
All water polo players were there.
But I had a secret.
And the secret was something that I was way subliminal,
but I was gay.
And how was I ever gonna tell my dad,
the Marine captain, Stephen senior not Stephen junior,
Chip of the old block that I was gay.
And so what happened was in my early 20s,
when I went to work for Morgan Stanley in New York,
that was the first time I ever walked into a gay bar.
And I was like, oh man, it was like in Wizard of Oz,
when it goes from black and white to Technicolor,
that's sort of what it felt like.
And I was like, okay, but it was hard.
And my process of coming out,
as someone who had been an all American athlete
and in a fraternity and the world I lived in was back then.
I mean, today it's a totally different story,
but back then it was pretty hard.
So fast forward a couple years later,
I am now the CEO at age 26 of a boutique hotel company.
Well, first let me just backtrack a little bit.
Yeah.
Like how did it go with Chip senior?
Chip senior-
Chip of the old block.
He really...
So dad actually initially took it well,
and then not so well.
And wanted me to go to reparative therapy.
I can talk about this stuff, okay.
So I ended up going to therapy
with a guy named Bernie Zilbergeld.
who wrote a book called "Male Sexuality."
He's no longer living.
And he set me up with a surrogate.
Because Bernie spent a bunch of time with me
and said, "Listen, dude you know, you might be bisexual,
"but I'm pretty sure you're straight.
"And you just need to have the right woman with you.
"And there's this woman, Annie.
"And Annie is so hot.
(Rich laughs)
"And so you're gonna have sex with Annie every two weeks.
"She's gonna report back to me
"about what actually happened."
And then you're just gonna (indistinct)-
Having sex (indistinct).
I have my lights (indistinct) out
and I'm gonna like, yeah actual sex.
And this is during AIDS.
This is 1984, 1983, '84, '85.
So of course we were safe and I was having sex with her,
but I was going back to Bernie and saying
you know, it doesn't same feel the same
as it did with Victor, (both laugh).
And so long story short is,
dad finally got used to the idea that reparative therapy
wasn't gonna work.
And the reason this is relevant to my boutique hotel career
is because when I started my hotel company,
there was an element for me like I needed to prove myself.
I needed to go say, okay, I am going to be successful.
And because I'll be successful, you will admire and like me
and therefore it's my way of making up
for the fact that I felt like
I had both disappointed my dad,
but also that I was not normal,
or I was not as good as my fraternity brothers
because I was gay and they were straight.
Right.
But you could have stayed at Morgan Stanley
and checked all of those boxes.
So there was something percolating telling you
that you needed to find a new and different way
that was more in alignment with your blueprint-
Isn't that interesting.
Be successful in that regard.
It's very interesting, Rich,
because there's an element for me.
Like somehow my true north knew.
And again, this is stereotyping,
but as a gay man, I had a great design eye.
Okay.
Is that inborn?
I don't know what it says about gay men.
But guess what?
Gay men tend to have that.
I'm pretty empathetic by nature.
I'm pretty good at understanding other people
and being open to being in service of them.
And so for all those reasons,
boutique hotels made a lot of sense.
And so I started this company.
It grows to be the second largest
boutique hotel company in the U.S.
Along the way, my sense of identity,
my sense of who I am from age 26 to let's say 47 or 48,
is dudes I am this founder and CEO of this company,
that's grown to 3,500 employees.
And then I had...
It's like the world changed almost overnight.
So it was early 2008,
and I could see the Great Recession coming
based upon our numbers.
I had written a book.
So I've written five books.
And my third book, I had written a few months earlier called
"Peak: How Great Companies Get Their Mojo from Maslow."
It became a huge hit.
And I was giving speeches on it, and I was loving that.
I loved writing, I loved speaking.
It's like all of a sudden,
like the thing that had been my calling,
there's a new calling (chuckles).
And the new calling is knocking on the door.
And I feel like a little bit unloyal, disloyal
because the new calling was this writing-speaking thing.
So I had a foster son, African American foster son
who was having some trouble with the law as an adult.
And I had a longterm relationship potentially ending.
I was running outta cash because of the Great Recession.
And then one of my closest friends
who has the exact same name, I have his name is Chip,
not exact name, first name.
So Chip takes his own life.
He dies by suicide.
And so to go to the funeral of a friend of yours
who has the exact same name, strange name.
And I was sort of in the early stage of a (indistinct)
of my own soul was really uncanny.
And then soon after that, so Gavin Newsom,
who's the governor of California
was my first mentee when I was 35 and he was 28.
Before he was the mayor of San Francisco,
before he was the governor of California.
So I went to his bachelor party at (indistinct) ballpark.
Yeah.
And I hit a triple out to the warning track
and I was sliding to third base at age 48, 47, 48.
I broke my ankle.
And then I got a septic condition in my leg.
And so I was on a strong antibiotic
and I was giving a speech in St. Louis.
And after the speech I was sitting in signing books
and I went flatlined.
I didn't go flatline I went unconscious.
Like literally at the signing table?
At the signing table, I went unconscious.
They put me on the ground.
I guess I was out for like four or five minutes.
They called the paramedics thankfully.
And I was on the ground.
And next thing I knew I was coming to,
I had no idea where I was or what had happened.
The paramedics put me on the gurney.
And that was the first time I went flatlined.
So I flatlined.
They had to bring out the paddles to shock me back to life.
And over the next 90 minutes,
I flatlined nine times in 90 minutes.
And what happened for me,
and how this relates to my whole history
was I had this moment of...
You know, we can talk about what it's like
to go to the other side.
Yeah, I definitely-
It was a true NDE.
I definitely want to hear more about that.
But what it really forced me to look at
is how I had the hotelier wake up call.
I had to look at my life and say, is this the life I want?
I was having I guess, a midlife crisis in some way.
But more than anything
I was having what Britney Brown, my friend, would call it
a midlife unraveling.
Like everything was so tightly wound
and it needed to unwind some.
And so-
Did you have self-awareness of that at the time?
Or were you kind of like pushing that down
and just in the kind of move forward?
I knew I was really unhappy.
I knew I wasn't unhappy.
I knew that when I was at Chip's funeral
and his memorial service,
and people were telling their Chip stories,
and I had thought about going
to the Golden Gate Bridge myself and jumping.
I really was at that place of saying,
I don't know how to disengage
from this identity I've created.
The identity that defined me
was this successful entrepreneur,
who's creative, who's created amazing culture.
Who happens to write books and give speeches
and do TED talks.
And all of this it was like the "Wizard of Oz."
It was a very aspirational identity
that anybody would want to have.
And obviously was the manifestation
of what you had dreamed about.
And-
So how could you be unhappy in that condition?
I was unhappy because I...
First of all, it wasn't creative enough.
Let's go back to that.
I had created a company that was a creativity company.
But by the time we had 3,500 employees,
and now we're in the Great Recession and we've grown,
opened 15 hotels in the last 21 months,
Like in the worst of times.
I was just trying to keep the lights on.
The lights on, yeah.
It's about spreadsheets (indistinct) people.
And I loved writing.
And then all this other stuff happening in my personal life.
My son, and foster son and my relationship ending.
And so what happened was I had this flatline experience.
I had "Man's Search for Meaning," Viktor Frankl's book
in my backpack.
My way of knowing how dark I was at that time was,
I was carrying around Viktor Frankl's book
as the reminder that I was not in a concentration camp.
The concentration camp was in my own mind.
In your mind, yeah, wow.
So while I was in the hospital
for a couple days while they were doing all these tests
and ultimately they sort of said,
"We think you're allergic to augmented,
"the antibiotic you're on."
So I was reading Viktor Frankl's book
about being in a concentration camp.
And I came up with an equation.
Despair equals suffering minus meaning.
So suffering's ever present.
And if you're a Buddhist,
that's the first truth of Buddhism
is suffering is ever present.
Then despair and meaning are inversely proportional.
So when you're going through a really crappy time,
the key is to ask yourself, what's the meaning.
And it really did take me 20 years back
to when I said, okay, my wisdom book
what did I learn this week?
I got very fixated on what am I learning?
What am I learning?
And what's the meaning in this?
And ultimately within two years, less than two years,
I'd sold the company at the bottom of the Great Recession.
I had ended the romantic relationship
I'd been in for a long time that wasn't working.
I'd gotten my foster son out of prison,
out of San Quentin because a federal judge let him out
and said, he's not guilty.
He's constitutional rights were abridged.
Wow.
And I was on a path to saying, I'm ready for the magic.
I mean, I'm ready to actually create space in my life
and see what emerges.
Because I've spent the last two dozen years
building this identity.
And it's not a facade.
I mean, the whole time I was living my truth,
but I was also getting to a place where I was so fixated
with the identity that I wasn't actually giving space
for the new creativity to come in.
And so, yeah.
And that it was not long after that,
that Airbnb came calling.
So in the midst of experiencing that level of despair
and the self-awareness that you had
to find or attach some meaning to it,
walk me through the process of how you identified that.
Because I think there's probably a lot of people
who are experiencing some level of despair.
It's been a really hard couple years.
Is the idea that there is universal meaning in all suffering
or is it that you have to find a personal connection,
like your own definition
of how it could be meaningful for you.
Well, let's use Frankl for a minute.
Viktor Frankl and folks were in the concentration camp.
What he says in his book is that when he saw people
having hope and had a sense of the other side of this,
not false hope.
The people who actually died quickly,
were the ones who said by this date,
we are gonna be outta here.
And that was a false hope,
because they had no control over them being released
by that date.
But there was more of a focus on hope
for what the future will be,
and how this experience will actually create
maybe a better life for them.
And so that's not a bad way to look at it,
because what we do know is that when we're going through
difficult times.
It is exceptionally character building.
It can be not for everybody.
Sometimes people give up.
Sometimes people do whatever they do
and where they drink, they use distractions.
They use alcohol, they use drugs, they use porn,
they use whatever it is to distract themselves
from the learning.
There is work sometimes as well.
So I think the key for me was to ask myself,
how is my character?
This may not be a resume builder, surviving a downturn.
So how do we...
You know to use some David Brooks thinking,
how do we move from the resume values to the eulogy values?
And the eulogy values are the values that people
will say about you at your funeral.
And they're the character qualities.
And I think it was around that age in my late 40s
that I realized I'd spent my life building a resume.
And I'd built some character qualities along the way,
but I was never really focused on
how am I developing those character qualities.
And if you want a time to develop your character qualities,
use the dark time to do that.
Because it's an exceptional time.
Sure.
And it's time where you actually often have to break habits.
Yeah, I have my own experience with that.
Yeah.
Tell us.
It's painful.
Well, I mean, I'm not gonna bore everyone
who's listening to this-
They're listening.
They're on this show because they (indistinct) you.
But I mean I had a version of that reckoning at 40,
and it was sort of a collision of a health scare
with an existential crisis about how I was living my life.
I was a corporate lawyer at the time and very unhappy,
but also very much in the checking the boxes
and trying to make sure that I was the dutiful son
to parents with high expectations, et cetera.
Something that you know quite well.
And had to really deconstruct all of that
and figure out who I wanted to be.
And then spent a decade trying to figure that out.
I'm still trying to figure it out.
And I found a modality that I leveraged
was endurance sports and all of the kind of quiet time
that comes with that,
that allowed me to develop a level of self connection
that I was lacking at the time.
And ultimately leading me
kind of into a more intuition-based, heart-centered place
to be open to what was next.
And Airbnb didn't call,
but slowly other opportunities came.
And that's kind of why I'm sitting here today.
And that evolution and having it be on display for others
has been incredibly cathartic to people to see your process.
Especially you're from 40 to 55, that is a...
I would say your curve of happiness
shows that 47.2 is the low point.
Again, your mileage may vary.
But from 40 to 55 a lot's going on.
I use another emotional equation.
Disappointment equals expectations minus reality.
So disappointment equals...
So it's around 40 to 50, 55
that you start to come face-to-face with the expectations
that you have for yourself.
The perfect spouse,
that you're supposed to be president of the United States.
How much wealth you're supposed to have.
The second home you're supposed to have.
The kids who are perfect.
And in your 40s, you come face-to-face with the fact
that none of that's actually happening.
And you also may come face-to-face
with the fact that this success script that you were handed
by your parents is not the script
that you wanna write for yourself.
And is not leading to the fulfillment
that was implicitly promised.
That's right.
And so lucky for me at 22 I came out of the closet
because it forced me to actually come face-to-face
with my success script from my parents.
And my lovely parents.
I love my parents
and they've been after rough, initial time,
they've been incredibly supportive and loving.
And love the fact that they're on a six week vacation
right now at age 84.
But what I can say is that being able to deconstruct
the success script,
in such a way that you recognize
that you're the screenwriter of your own life,
and you need sometimes some guidance
for how to write that screenplay.
Partly because you may have constructed your life
in a certain way.
And it's not just like, oh, okay,
now I'm gonna go do this other thing.
No, you actually have three kids
and you get a spouse and you've got a mortgage,
and you're actually helping your ailing parents.
At the same time you're helping your teenagers.
So you've got the sandwich generation going on.
And so the process of doing that...
I witnessed my father.
My father who dutifully became a banker like his father
around his early 40s, said you know, fuck this.
I don't wanna do this.
And he created a business when he had me at Stanford,
my sister about to go to Stanford,
and then another sister gonna go to UC Berkeley
a few years later.
And he started a company at a time
where it was really not opportune.
So my father's been a role model for me in many ways.
It's interesting.
And it is around our 40s and 50s,
and some people's reaction to all that is,
go get the red Ferrari.
Or have the affair.
And I mean, often that's just another form of a distraction.
Yeah, I want to get into the mentorship piece.
But before that, I'm not letting you off the hook
on that near death experience.
Oh, yeah.
I want to hear what that was like specifically.
Well, since it happened nine times in 90 minutes,
and I had one particular nurse there by my side,
four of those nine times,
and each time I would come out of my NDE,
I would say to her, here's what I saw.
And she would say to me, "That's what you said last time."
And the last time was only about six minutes ago.
So here's what I saw.
And I've hung out with a lot of NDE folks.
There's even a...
I'm fascinated by festivals
because I've a founding board member
of the Burning Man Nonprofit.
And there's a festival in Northwestern Spain
called the Pilgrimage of the Near Death Experience.
And everybody who had death experience is put in a coffin
that's open and you have a parade
of coffins going down the street.
My you're waving in everybody, and everybody's drinking
and it sounds sort of weird and macabre.
So my experience was this,
the first thing I noticed was
that I was in a mountain chalet.
So maybe let's say eight or 10,000 feet
in some mountain range.
It was like maybe a summer day.
I didn't notice any snow.
But there was this huge skylight in the living room,
the upstairs living room.
And the skylight was open and there was light coming in,
and there was a kaleidoscope of colors
that was actually being projected onto the wall.
I was about maybe eight or 10 feet in the air,
just sort of floating.
I didn't see myself, I didn't observe myself.
I just knew I was not on the ground.
I was sort of observing from that place.
There were birds chirping.
It was gorgeous.
I mean, it was sort of quite beautiful.
And then the thing that was most noticeable
was on the ground was this beautiful wood floor.
And on the ground,
there was this frangipani scented.
So like a tropically scented oil that was very thick,
like a viscous oil.
That was actually made.
It created a sheen on the floor.
And the oil was going toward the staircase going downstairs.
But it's sort of like that Heinz 57 commercial anticipation.
It's like the oil was dripping down the stairs
exceptionally slowly.
So what I noticed more than anything of around this,
there's no other people, there was no white light,
other than this light coming from the skylight.
Which was like a white light
that led to the kaleidoscope of colors on the wall.
What I noticed is how sensual it all was,
the listening to the birds,
the smelling of the frangipani,
the beauty of it all.
At some point, I actually touched...
My arm projected longer, so I could touch the ground
and touch the oil.
And I think more than anything,
what I felt was this sense of spaciousness and slowness.
In 2005, we opened the hotel Vitale.
And the hotel Vitale had slippers in the room,
and one slipper said slow and the other slippers said down.
So if you had your slippers on, it said slow down.
And that was one of my ideas for this hotel
that was supposed to be almost like a spa hotel
in the financial district.
Slow down.
So I was in my own NDE that was just telling me
to slow down.
That is the experience I had.
That's what I take from it.
The other thing I take.
Because again, the dripping of the oil was so slow.
So I might be out for two minutes or three minutes
when I had my NDE,
and I'd come back and I felt like I'd been out
for hours or days.
But more than anything what I got from it,
was just this deep sense of just slowing down.
And when I slowed down,
I realized that I'd spent my life running away
from my emotions.
And what I recognized was that,
because the recession had come on
and I was trying to figure out
how to keep my company afloat.
I was just a manic, crazy person.
And I didn't wanna be that one anymore.
And I'd spent since age 21 meditating,
but I'd stopped meditating at that point.
I was no longer meditating.
And so my exercise,
I started practicing my meditation every morning
and late in the day.
And I just slowed my life down.
And as I slowed my life down,
I realized that I thought I loved what I was doing.
And I did in some ways my ego did.
But one of the things that Carl Jung
and Christian mystic Richard Rohr have talked about
is the fact that...
And Richard Rohr has come to our Modern Elder Academy.
Oh, wow.
As a student.
Amazing.
As a student at 79 years old.
Really?
Yes.
You didn't-
We'll talk about this,
when we talk about MEA.
So what I noticed was that when I slowed down,
my ego started to melt and Richard Warren,
Carl Jung had both said that your primary operating system
for the first half of your life is your ego.
And for the second half of your adult life, it's your soul.
And yet none of us are issued operating instructions
of how to move from driving automatic
to driving stick shift.
And it's almost like you're on a San Francisco hilly road
during rainstorm,
and you're on Hyde Street trying to drive up
with the cable car.
The metal from the cable car tracks,
meaning you're spinning your wheels.
Because the process of moving from ego to soul,
or from automatic to stick shift,
there's a complexity to it.
And I had to have an NDE to recognize it
and to slow down to see
that I needed an operating system shift.
And that's what happened.
And it's a deeper, longer story than that.
And I wrote a book called "Emotional Equations" about it.
But it was ultimately the thing that helped me to say,
get outta jail free Chip.
You don't have to die.
You don't have to be like your friendship
who had took his own life.
And I can start rewriting the script
of how I wanna live my life.
And ultimately my experience going to Airbnb
was a perfect segue for me,
because instead of being the Sage on the stage,
the heroic CEO, I was the guide on the side.
Right.
Worker among workers.
I was the worker amongst workers.
And I was the guy helping these three founders
along with some other people.
And it was not just me.
But I was really tightly wound with them
to help them be successful.
It's sort of like what a parent does with a child.
Your ego doesn't have a space in that relationship.
Yeah, what a beautiful insight and experience
to take this thing and attach meaning to it.
It's such a specific experience, right?
Yeah.
And in the many kind of flat lines that you had,
that same vision occurred to you.
Oh yeah.
The nurse kept saying, "You're so funny.
"You keep telling me the same thing."
Right.
What do you make of that?
I mean you could say,
well, this is your unconscious mind,
your subconscious trying to get your attention.
Or you can go down a more metaphysical rabbit hole
with the whole thing.
You being on the board of Burning Man,
and all of that (chuckles),
I'm gonna predict that you're seeing this
as more of a metaphysical experience.
Yeah.
I mean, I saw it as this opportunity...
I mean, I saw it as an opportunity
for me to have the courage to change everything.
And the metaphysical side of it
was very much this divine intervention
and this sense like, okay, you get another chance, Chip.
You're not ready to go,
but you're ready to be reborn in a different way.
Yeah, for sure.
Interestingly, my first hotel was called the Phoenix.
The mythological bird that rises from its own ashes.
So I was ready to be regenerated,
which we'll talk about in a few minutes.
I was ready for a regeneration.
but I didn't know how to do that.
And that's actually...
There's a lot of people who are sort of in that place
of realizing this isn't working anymore.
I don't need to have an NDE to learn that.
But how do I re-script my life?
How do I sculpt it in a different way?
How do I break through the blocks and the habits
that are in my way.
Yeah and I think tragically all too many
may have some version of that epiphany,
but are feeling trapped in the circumstances of their life,
due to the things that you mentioned.
The mortgage, the responsibilities, et cetera.
And so then they live out the remaining days in tension
between those two things,
and unable to kind of figure out a path forward
that would kind of resolve that internal conflict.
Yep.
Sorry to interrupt the flow.
We'll be right back with more awesome.
But I wanna snag a moment to talk to you
about the importance of nutrition.
The thing is most people I know,
actually already know how to eat better
and aspire to incorporate more whole plants.
More fruits, vegetables, seeds, beans,
and legumes into their daily routine.
Sadly, however, without the kitchen tools
and support very few end up sticking with it.
So because adopting a plant-based diet
transformed my life so profoundly.
And because I want everybody to experience
some version of what I've experienced,
we decided to tackle and solve this very common problem.
The solution we've devised,
I'm proud to say is the plant power meal planner,
our affordable all in one digital platform
that sets you up for nutrition excellence,
by providing access to thousands of highly customizable,
super delicious and easy to prepare plant-based recipes.
Everything integrates with automatic grocery delivery
and you get access to our amazing team of nutrition coaches,
seven days a week.
And many other features.
To learn more and to sign up, visit meals.richroll.com.
And right now, for a limited time,
we're offering $10 off an annual membership,
when you use the promo code RRHEALTH at checkout.
This is life changing stuff people for just $1.70 a week,
literally the price of a cup of coffee.
Again, that's meals.rich.com.
Promo code RRHEALTH for $10 off an annual membership.
All right, let's get back to the show.
Let's talk about mentorship.
Because when I think of you, and I look at you
in the limited amount of time that we spent together.
To me, you're this wise teacher,
like you you have the teacher gene.
I think you thrive in circumstances
whether it's on stage or one-on-one
and in the Modern Elder Academy
where you're imparting some experience based wisdom
that you've accumulated.
I know you studied philosophy in college, et cetera.
My sense is that it feels very natural to you.
Not that it isn't like sort of trained over the years,
but the mentorship thing to me feels
like you're real self-seeking out earlier in life,
before the NDE and all of that.
I mean, the fact that at 35, you're mentoring Gavin Newsom,
like when did the mentorship thing start
and how has that become a thing?
Like kind of what role does that play
in terms of you being a mentor
and the importance of mentorship in general?
So quite specifically with Gavin,
he was an hospitality entrepreneur.
He had a company called PlumJack.
I remember that living in San Francisco in the early 90s.
Exactly, there was a wine store
and there was a restaurant.
And then there was a hotel.
Like right on Philmore, the union street area-
Yeah, exactly Cow Hollow.
Long story short is his sister came to me,
Hillary, and she said "You know my brother could learn
"a few things from you."
And I'd met her a few times and I'd met him,
but I didn't know him as well as I knew her.
"Would you be open to mentoring him?"
And of course she hadn't asked him about this.
And I said, sure.
And partly she had read,
at that point I think I had written maybe...
No, actually hadn't written a book yet.
But I'd written some columns, some business columns.
And she just sort of knew who I was.
So long story short is every Friday,
Gavin would come down to my office in Union Square
from his offices in Cow Hollow in San Francisco,
and we'd sit down and talk.
And then ultimately he had brought me
into his PlumpJack organization to help mentor
some of the other leaders there
and lead some offsite retreats for them.
And then he ran for the board of supervisors
in San Francisco.
So he became one of the board of supervisors,
which is like the city council.
And then he became mayor.
And when he became mayor, that's where it amped up.
Because now here's this guy who's...
I don't know, at that point he was in his 30s, I think.
Pretty young.
Yeah, he was in his late thirties when he became mayor,
if I'm not mistaken or early 40s.
But he was a very young mayor,
and San Francisco was going through a really difficult time.
And so now I showed up at his office every Friday,
he was showing up at my office in the early days.
Yeah.
Now I'm showing up at city hall room 200
and being his counseliary .
I mean, I was sort of like the person
he sought counsel from, and then he did the same thing.
So with his like, the chief of police and the fire chief,
and the head of human services
and we would actually do offsite retreats (chuckles)
and I would help mentor some of them.
And so that was a fascinating experience.
And then he ultimately became governor
and we still stay in touch pretty closely.
It's a trip though.
Like you're like, what am I doing?
I mean, mentoring the mayor of San Francisco (laughs).
Well, it's weird.
It was like Chip.
Everybody in the office knew Chip brings Gavin's lunch
and Chip's lunch in these sacks.
And there's actually San Francisco magazine
once did a story about.
It's like this picture of me coming to Gavin's office
with a sack lunch.
And I've been lucky enough to be the mentor
for the Burning Man, CEO.
Marian Goodell, Liz Lambert, one of the best known
boutique hoteliers in the U.S.
And of course, Brian Chesky and others.
What I love about mentorship is,
in a great mentorship relationship
you as the mentor may learn as much as they will.
And when I was at Airbnb, I had over 100 mentees
over the course of seven and a half years, which is a lot.
And I learned as much from them as they did from me.
And Brian once said this to me.
Brian Chesky once said this to me.
He said, "Chip, you teach me EQ and I teach you DQ."
EQ being emotional intelligence,
DQ being digital intelligence.
And I think if we could look at mentorship,
we have five generations in the workplace
for the very first time.
And if we could realize it.
And here's a couple other stats,
for over 40% of Americans now,
have a boss that's younger than them.
So my relationship with Brian was not as unusual
as it might have been 25 years ago.
So we have something to learn from each other
and being able to create mutual mentorship relationships,
where one person knows one thing,
that the other person wants to learn and vice versa.
It wouldn't take a lot of matchmaking technology
in a large company to match employees as mentors.
Because quite frankly,
the beautiful thing about a mentorship relationship
is it's free form, it's affordable, doesn't cost anything.
And bottom line is Deloitte has shown in their studies
that when people have a mentor in an organization,
they are substantially
more likely to stay in the organization.
And an era like we are in right now
with the great resignation,
where companies are saying we're losing people
left and right.
One of the best things you could do
not just for wisdom and knowledge transfer,
but also for retention is create mentorship programs
within an organization.
Right.
There's great kinship between the idea of mentorship
and the modern elder idea, right?
Yes.
Before we move off of this, though,
I think I'd like to hear a few thoughts
on going about finding a mentor,
or soliciting your services as a mentor.
I think there's a lot of people who think mentorship
means I'm gonna email Seth Godin
every single day for two years,
until he finally relents and becomes my mentor.
We think of these fancy names.
Yeah.
People that we would like to have on call,
but that's not really the heart of what it is.
Like, I'm always talking about the fact
that there are mentors all around you.
That's right.
Like find the people in your environment,
and figure out how you can contribute to their lives,
if you're gonna solicit their input into yours.
Yeah.
And be careful of like leading with the M word.
Like marriage.
Marriage, it's like, whoa.
The M word, marriage.
Like if you pop the marriage question on the second day,
it's absolute mess, right?
(both laugh)
I know you.
Yeah, exactly.
So the way I would go about it on either side
mentor or mentee.
But maybe let's start with the mentee side is,
let's say, there's somebody you wanna learn from.
Just say, hey, could I take you out for coffee?
Or could we go have tea?
Or can we just have a meal together?
And if they're in your same organization,
the likelihood is that they're gonna say yes.
If it's the CEO and you've been in the company
a month as an intern,
they may not say yes, if it's a huge company.
But one of the ways to pose it is to say,
hey, let's just have a little meal.
And I just would love to tap into your wisdom.
I mean, don't be shy about saying something like that.
Or even more specific you say,
I've noticed that you're really good at fill in the blank.
I would like to learn from you.
Can we just get together once and have a conversation.
And then don't expect a bigger commitment than that.
But then have the one time conversation.
And if it goes really well,
and you can see that they're enjoying it as the mentor
say, in a month from now, could we maybe get together again?
And they're likely to say yes, do it again.
And at that point, if that second one is great,
then say, are you open to us maybe creating
like a short term mentor relationship.
Maybe we get together once a month,
or every two weeks, for an hour, and I ask questions
and you gimme some homework assignments, et cetera.
At the point where you're ready to ask that,
get specific about what you're looking for.
And be clear that you're committed to it.
I mean, the worst experience for a mentor
is when a mentee goes through that whole process
and then doesn't take it seriously.
Doesn't show up for the meeting.
Or you know says, okay, well I don't have time right now,
or et cetera.
Make the time.
If you're not willing to make the time,
then don't actually make the ask.
But also give it a finite period,
because that way the other person doesn't feel like, oh, no.
This is a lifelong commitment.
Yeah.
The other thing I would just say,
is there's two kinds of mentorship.
There's mentorship, that's performance.
What I would call performance based,
and then development based.
Performance based is like finite.
It's more of a mentorship relationship
where you have information I want to learn,
I need to ask you questions.
And you'll be my mentor,
but it'll be a finite relationship
because I wanna learn more about how to run a great meeting,
how to understand the travel industry,
how to I don't know, code.
To do simple coding.
So that's finite relationship.
It's performance-driven in the sense that over the course
of a short period of time,
you can determine if you've gotten better at that.
So you can have a lot of mentees
if there's sort of like that.
They're like, okay, yeah,
you can ask me questions every once in a while.
And I understand you wanna learn about this thing.
The other kind of relationship
is a developmental relationship,
and it's a lot more comprehensive.
And it's more personal, professional, emotional, EQ.
And that's when somebody really just wants a guide.
You know one of my mentees called me her confidant.
And I said, wow, okay,
give me some juicy gossip. (chuckles).
And she said, well, no, no.
And she's French.
She said, "When I say confidant,
"and I mean it in sort of the French way,
"you're the one who gives me confidence."
So it wasn't knowledge transfer.
It wasn't a knowledge transfer
which the first kind of relationship is.
It's like I'm transferring knowledge.
The second kind of relationship is one that's more personal.
And actually the person who's asking the questions
is not the mentee.
The person who's asking the questions is the mentor.
And I'm asking questions about you,
to help you unlock who you are,
and help you guide you be your permissionery.
To help give you the permission to do the things
I think that you have the capability of doing.
A lot of people think
that's what a mentorship relationship is, and it is.
But this first kind is the more finite kind
and you allows you to have many relationships
because it's specific to a knowledge transfer.
Yeah.
So being able to understand what kind of relationship
a person wants when it comes to mentorship,
is pretty important.
Not to push back,
but how many emails a day do you get from people
asking to take you out for a cup of coffee?
(Chip laughs)
You see, that's the thing-
It's nice to live in (indistinct) most of the time,
because I'm not-
I Get a lot of those emails and it's just like,
I can't do that.
Like, I'm not of a position to do that.
So I think it is really about who are the people
in your environment.
Yeah.
I mean, when it's...
Listen, if someone has come from out of the blue
and I don't know them at all,
I mean, I do get a lot of emails from people
and they tweet me up with all the things
that they know I'll probably want to hear.
And in those kinds of cases,
I'm not gonna get on a Zoom call with them,
but I will answer two or three questions by in an email.
I'll do that.
And so for those of you who are listening
to business now,
and you wanna send me an email with a couple questions,
feel free to do that
because I had people who helped me early on.
There are times when I may say, oh man,
I am barrage right now.
So I'm gonna have my assistant
actually tell you to write me back in a month or six months.
And then maybe I can answer some questions.
But most of the time I do answer questions
by email pretty quickly,
assuming they're really simple answers.
But in terms of like someone saying,
"Hey, can I get to do a quick Zoom call with you."
It's like, I think one of the lessons we've learned
in the last two years,
is doing a simple Zoom call will wear you out.
If you do 12 of those in a row.
And so for me, I also like to test somebody.
If someone comes to me and says
they want some of my time and I'm really, really barraged
with stuff right now, and I can't give any time,
like come back to me in three months or six months.
If they come back to me in three or six months,
and I can see that they've got something,
I'll take it a little more seriously.
Not because I didn't take them seriously the first time,
but because they've shown me they have some reliability,
and some desire.
And therefore I'm gonna try to reciprocate if I can.
I wanna talk about what it means
to be a modern elder defining what a modern elder is.
But to kind of contextualize it.
When I think of your tenure at Airbnb coming in as a mentor,
kind of emerging from that as this modern elder,
and the success that relationship engendered
in terms of the company's prosperity.
It seems to me that should be like a Harvard Business School
case study.
Maybe it is, I don't know.
But because it was so fruitful and productive,
why doesn't every company institute some version of that?
Because it was so valuable.
The good news is the venture capital community
and private equity community took notice,
and it led to a lot of those companies sort of saying,
how are we going to...
The way venture capital and private equity works
is often the person who's put in charge of the young CEO
is a young partner or young associate at the venture capital
or private equity firm.
So they're not necessarily the person who has-
It's not Bill Burley.
It's not Bill Gurley,
and it's not somebody who's really gonna have the wisdom
or maybe the cohonest so to speak,
to say to the person who's outta control,
you're outta control.
So what I think we're starting to see is a recognition
that for their most high profile successful companies,
they better have a gray hair in the midst.
And not just showing up once a month at a meeting,
but actually creating a mentorship relationship.
You're also seeing a lot more coaches
being almost assigned to young CEOs,
such that the coach has that role.
Now that's not a bad thing as well.
Coaches can be spectacular,
but often if the coach doesn't have
the operating experience,
they may not be able to keep up with the young CEO
when they're talking about what's going on.
Right.
And this is pretty specific
to kind of youth culture driven business startup culture.
Yep.
But in truth, like the Fortune 500,
the Coca-Colas like these huge companies,
are the opposite.
It's cool of gray hairs.
The whole C-suite is ancient.
It's almost like they need a young mentor
who will be taken seriously to say,
here's why you're gonna be completely out of business
in five years, unless you listen
to kind of what my generation is looking for.
Yeah.
You're exactly right.
Ageism works in both directions.
A lot of times when we heard the word ageism,
at least in my world, I think of like older people
who are being discriminated against.
It's the opposite as well,
young people being discriminated against,
or not being given the opportunity to have a voice
in organizations that could use some shaking up.
So yeah, it definitely goes both ways.
So, I mean, I think...
I would say that we're living in an era
where this idea of an intergenerational potluck
where we all bring to the table that which we do
or know best, makes a lot of sense.
Yeah.
And there's a huge amount of research on this.
So diversity often in companies
doesn't think about age diversity.
We talk about race, gender, ethnicity, sexual orientation,
but like, okay, age diversity's important as well.
And there's a bunch of studies that have come out recently
that have shown that when you create age diverse teams,
you get the best of both worlds.
You get that brilliance, that focus, that quick thinking,
young spirit, along with the ability to metabolize,
or think holistically
and think beyond their own ego,
and actually create that psychological safety.
Fascinating study Google did,
that showed that psychological safety was the number one
ingredient of effective teams.
And psychological safety is helped
by having age diversity on a team.
So I think we're in the early stages
of realizing that age is an important diversity metric,
just like the other ones.
Sure.
For that to work, and be productive.
For that dynamic to be functional between older and younger,
it does require a level of like respect and humility.
And the capacity to listen and take seriously
what the other person is saying.
Because I think both camps sort of look at each other
as dumb dumbs.
Like, oh, these old people, they're checked out,
they don't know what they're doing.
These young people their brains
aren't even fully formed yet,
why should I listen to these people?
Yeah, this is part of the reasons there's...
I'm looking forward to doing something later this year.
I'll mention it now,
but we don't even have a website up for it yet.
There's a guy, Michael Hebb,
who started "Death Over Dinner."
So it's a movement globally.
Over a million people have done this.
Where they have this Jeffersonian dinners
topics, conversations about the subject of death.
And you could have one of three or four
or five different topics
that you and a few friends can actually talk about
over dinner.
Well, I think generations over dinner.
Generations over dinner, is an idea whose time has come.
I like that.
Which means you bring a bunch of generations.
Like three generations, five generations,
maybe even seven generations.
We have seven generations living still.
Bring them to a table and have a topic
about how do you solve climate change?
How do you address intergenerational collaboration
in the workplace?
What happens in the various life stages?
And the wisdom would go in both directions.
And you could sort of say,
oh, we just had a six generation dinner.
Or we had a four generation dinner.
And so it's something we're gonna be launching
later this summer.
We have a nonprofit called AGE,
the Association for Growth and Education,
that focuses on intergenerational collaboration.
And so keep an eye out for that.
That's cool, I really like that.
The "Generations Over Dinner."
Yeah, I really like that idea.
All right let's talk about the Modern Elder Academy.
So walk me through this epiphany,
and how you've created this amazing thing out of that idea.
Yeah.
So I went down to Baja,
so Southern Baja near Cabo San Lucas,
about an hour North place called Toes Santos Pescadero area
on the beach.
I had a home there.
And I was gonna start writing my fifth book
called "Wisdom at Work The Making of a Modern Elder."
So as I'm writing that book,
I'm going for runs on the beach.
And one day I went for a run on the beach
and I had a Baja aha.
I had an epiphany.
(laughs)
As one is, want to do.
Yes, exactly.
We like, this is an area where there is a midwife
for epiphanies.
It's like something strange about this particular area
that I live in.
And the epiphany I had was this,
is that the word adolescence didn't exist in 1903.
In 1904 it came to into being, because a psychologist
named Stanley Hall created it and said,
"Hey, there's a life stage
"that happens between puberty and 18."
And you're still a child,
but you're on the threshold of adulthood.
And you're going through emotional
and physical and identity transitions.
Okay.
And then after 1904, now we had public junior high schools
and high schools more prevalent.
You had child labor laws.
You had people not getting married at age 14,
and having babies when they're 15.
So long story short is adolescence became a thing.
Well, about 20 years ago,
a new term got a coin called middlescence.
Middlescence is the adult corollary to adolescence.
And it's when you're going through physical and hormonal
and identity transitions,
often between around age 40 and 60.
So the core of midlife.
So I had this run and I came back and said,
why do we not have any middlescence school?
We have adolescent, we give all this guidance
and schools and tools, and rights of passage and rituals
for people in adolescence.
But we have nothing for middlescence.
And what if we were to create the world's first midlife
wisdom school?
A place where people come to cultivate
and harvest their wisdom, and reimagine and repurpose it.
And so this was about four and a half years ago
I had the idea.
We opened January, 2018,
and we've had now 2,200 people from 33 countries
come to our programs.
Usually a week long program in Baja,
but we also have programs online as well.
And the whole intent is to help people
to reframe their relationship with aging.
And interestingly enough, the average age is 54,
but 15%, 14% of the people who come are millennials.
So this is not just people-
That's super interesting.
Isn't interesting, that people in their 30s-
And the motivation is I just wanna be in a growth mindset
and thinking about this before it becomes you know-
And I wanna start to mine my wisdom.
And I also want to be around people 20 years older than me
to learn from their wisdom.
So, yeah, and we have a great faculty.
We have everybody from Paul Hawken,
who's been on your show, to Michael Franti, the musician.
Matthieu Ricard, the famous Buddhist monk,
Sherry Lansing has done shows for us.
John Donahoe, CEO of Nike
is on our upcoming purpose online course.
So lots of really interesting people
who are helping all of us
to reframe that relationship with aging
and look at how we might regenerate ourselves.
Because the narrative we have about aging is you age,
you work and you're retired.
You have three stages in life.
You learn till you're 20 or 25.
You earn 'til you're 60 or 65.
And then you retire till you die.
And if you look at a millennial today, they're like,
what the hell is that tyranny of the three stage life?
I wanna actually work.
I'm gonna learn until I'm 20 or 25,
and then I'm gonna work for 10 years
and then I'm gonna take a year off.
I'm gonna do a gap here.
And then I'm gonna go get a master's, I'm gonna learn again.
And then I'm gonna go retire.
I'm gonna work for 10 years and start a company
and then retire, and then go back and get a PhD.
And it's more episodic.
Yeah.
It's not like you have these three stages of life
that are age defined.
And so that led us with MEA becoming very popular
and led us to creating regenerative communities.
And these idea of, let's get rid of the idea
of retirement communities.
Yeah, this is the real exciting part.
Rich are you gonna live in retirement communities someday?
It's the most depressing, horrific aspect of our culture
to just warehouse old people and hide them.
It's a form of age apartheid.
Let's like take those people and put them in a place
where we can't see them, so they're with each other.
And let's also recognize that frankly,
earlier generations sort of saw it
and our parents may have enjoyed it.
But there's also this weird sense that back in the old days,
if you were working on the factory floor,
or you were a school teacher your whole life,
you got to 60 and you said,
thank God I'm retiring,
because I can't do the factory floor work anymore.
Or I'm just so tired of this work,
or being a house cleaner or whatever it was.
And we have a lot more knowledge workers today.
And I think we have a lot more wisdom workers.
That's a phrase that I think is gonna come into being.
But the knowledge workers they can work till their 70s
or their 80s, or whenever.
It's not physical labor that actually defines
how they get paid.
And so more and more of them are of the mindset.
Like I don't wanna retire,
or I can't afford to retire.
If I'm gonna live 'til 90 or 95, I can't retire at 62.
And also that generation is far more inclined
to be pursuing work that has personal meaning to them.
We're our legacy is that three chapter
kind of approach to life.
That's what our parents did.
And we kind of were reared with that sensibility.
And now we're in our 50s and 60s,
and a lot of us are having those kind of crisis moments.
But over the course of those many decades, leading up to it,
there is a calcification around mindset.
This is who I am.
This is what I do.
Here's what I can expect for my life.
Here's how I see the world.
This is the people that I vote for.
And these are the things that I talk about.
So one of the critical kind of tools that you leverage
at the Modern Elder Academy,
that I wanna hear a little bit more about
is just getting really clear on what your mindset is.
So that you can begin the process of deconstructing it
and perhaps telling yourself a new story.
Yeah.
Well, so there's four key pillars of our curriculum.
The first one's reframing aging,
helping people to see that maybe their best years
are ahead of them.
Can this be aspirational?
It can be.
And some things get better with age.
I love that your listeners and your community
is very much about keeping the body alive.
Certain things get actually better with age.
You know your emotion.
Your emotional intelligence grows with age,
your spiritual awareness grows with age.
So there's a lot of things
that actually get better with age.
And yes, if you work on your body
and your health, and your nutrition,
it might get better with age as well.
You're a great example of that.
So there's that reframing aging.
Then there's mindset.
So there's growth in fixed mindset.
We're big fans of Carol Dweck's work at Stanford.
And so a fixed mindset is when you tend to think of life,
as I'm here to prove myself,
and I define success as winning.
The problem if you have that point of view,
as you get older is you stop playing
the games you can't win.
And that means your sandbox gets smaller and smaller.
And as it gets smaller, you actually get more bored
because you're not trying new things.
So moving from a fix to a growth mindset,
means moving from proving yourself, to improving yourself.
And instead of focusing on winning, you focus on learning.
And so you move into this way of thinking
and way of being of, okay, I am just a learning machine.
I'm not a machine, I'm a learning human.
One of the questions we ask at MEA is
what is it that you know now,
or have you done now, that you wish you had known
or done 10 years ago?
Think about that for a moment.
And then ask yourself 10 years from now,
what will you regret if you don't learn it or do it now?
And this is how I started to learn how to surf at age 57,
because I live on a beach near a surf break,
somewhat famous one.
And I was like, ain't gonna be any easier
at 67 than 57, Chip.
So I gotta start learning that.
I also started learning Spanish.
Again, the mantra in my head,
the mindset was I'm too old for this,
too old to learn the language.
But harder to learn it at 67 than 57.
And I knew that I was gonna be living in Mexico,
so why not learn it?
So the first is reframing aging.
The second is shifting your mindset.
The third is learning about transitions.
None of us were taught and got a master's in TQ,
transitional intelligence.
But midlife is full of transitions.
Life is full of transitions.
Life is liminal you're usually in between two things.
And yet we've never really been taught.
What's the anatomy of that transition,
and how do I architect moving through a transition,
whether it's getting divorced,
or changing where I live, or changing my career or retiring,
or seeing my parents to passing away.
Or becoming an empty nester, or going through menopause,
or men go through andropause.
There's a lot of transitions in midlife,
and learning how to understand the three stages
of a transition is a big part of our program.
And then the final piece of the curriculum is regeneration.
In all its forms.
We have regenerative cell therapy.
I mean, stem cell work.
Regeneration through understanding a regenerative purpose.
But also, and this is where Paul Hawken comes in
regenerative agriculture and farming.
And that's what leads us to our regenerative communities.
Our first one being in Baja with 26 homes
around a regenerative farm.
So instead of living on a fairway,
wouldn't you like to live on a farm.
And go out into the farm and go harvest with your neighbors
and do a potluck once a week.
And so now we're taking this to Santa Fe.
And we have three different properties in Santa Fe,
two of which will be academies,
one of which will be a regenerative residential community.
And I do believe that we are creating something
that is meant to disrupt senior living.
Right.
It disrupts higher education, some form of education.
And then this whole kind of area that's so bright
for disruption.
Yeah.
Senior living.
But it's leveraging all this experience
that you had as a hotelier.
Like it's not that dissimilar.
Like, oh, I'm gonna disrupt the hotel industry.
I understand that skillset.
Now I'm gonna apply it to this other area
that desperately we need something better and healthier.
I think that's really exciting.
I've been lucky.
Lucky to a disruptor twice in the hospitality industry.
First as a boutique hotelier, and then at Airbnb.
You know, you don't start something to disrupt it.
I mean, that's not the intent.
You start something because you have an idea.
It's a natural outgrowth of everything you're doing.
That's right.
You have an idea, and then the idea sort of takes off.
And then we hear from people saying,
Chip, long life learning.
That's what you're doing.
You're not doing lifelong learning.
You're doing long life learning.
And more and more colleges and universities
who are in the process of being disrupted
in all kinds of ways right now.
Clay Christiansen, the guy who created the term
disruptive innovation.
Before he passed away, five years ago,
said 50% of the colleges and universities
in the United States will be out of business
in 10 to 15 years.
So colleges and universities need to start thinking
about midlife wisdom schools, or these places-
And to be fair,
a lot of colleges are doing programs,
but it's sort of traditional curriculum oriented.
It's accumulating knowledge.
It's more like I'm going-
It's not experiential.
I'm a 50 year old sitting in a classroom of 20 year olds
and I'm learning biology or I'm learning philosophy.
But it actually isn't...
I wrote a white paper
called the emergence of long life learning.
To study with a PhD who wrote it with me,
how do people learn differently at 55?
What's important to them, how do they learn differently?
And that actually had a huge impact
on how we have created our curriculum,
because we actually at MEA,
wisdom is not taught it's shared.
So how do you create the crucible
for a collection of 20 people over the course of a week?
To learn a bunch of things,
but then actually share experience
and in small diad partners, one on one with each other,
have these conversations of how it's applicable to them.
And how it's gonna be applicable to you at 55 or at 45
is different than it is at 25.
So yes, lifelong learning is a thing.
But long life learning is a subset of it,
focused on how to live a life that's as deep and meaningful
as it is long.
Because we have gotten the quantity right.
Longevity has grown a lot.
The quality is the thing
that I think people need to focus more on.
A big piece in trying to engender your life
with that level of quality
is this transition that you speak about
from accumulation to attunement?
So speak about that a little bit.
Yeah, the first half for our life is about accumulating.
Accumulating knowledge and friends
and obligations and romantic partners,
and then marriage possibly and children.
You get to age 45 or so, and you say, oh my god,
I've got this burden.
I've got a lot of baggage.
And the second half of your life
is now about editing that baggage.
So you move from accumulating to editing,
and you move from the attainment part of your life.
And it doesn't mean you don't have attainment
throughout your life, you do.
But I gotta tell you,
and as someone who's like a first class attainer,
your attainment at some point as your ego starts to shift
that operating system of the ego shifts to the soul,
you move from attaining to attuning.
What's the difference?
When you're in the attainment mode,
you will atone later because you may have sharp elbows.
(Rich laughs)
You're sort of like,
when you're actually attaining,
you're very selfishly focused.
And you might be a gracious person,
but you are deeply focused on the finish line.
And that's the hedonic treadmill.
It's when we sort of realized,
man, I keep putting finish lines there
and I feel a sense of accomplishment,
but I don't necessarily feel the sense of happiness.
And so moving from attainment to attunement
moves from attorning afterwards to feeling at one.
So when you're in the attune phase,
you're sort of like harmonizing.
So surfing is an attunement sport.
You better attune with the wave.
So many things as we get older,
become attunement, opportunities for attunement.
And as we learn how to attune,
we actually know how to create
sort of that psychological safety in a team.
We know how to actually create
what's called environmental mastery.
This is something we get better at as we get older.
It's not about the ecosystem or the dirt on the ground.
Environmental mastery means you actually know
how to report yourself in the right habitats and flourish.
It's a psychological quality.
It's a social science research that shows
that as we get older, we understand where we will flourish
and you are better and more adept at being able to discern
where that will be.
And so that becomes a part of it as well.
And that's attuning with the right environment.
It's part of the reason why, frankly, at age 50,
we sort of get to a place where like,
I have no more fucks to give.
And I'm not talking about someone's romantic life.
I'm actually talking about,
I don't want to be in an environment
that it feels toxic to me.
You might handle it in your 20s or your 30s,
maybe even your 40s.
But in your 50s, your level of patience for it
isn't the same.
And one person's toxicity
maybe another person's beautiful environment.
So I'm not saying all environment-
Right
But there's a freedom and like kind of a liberation
and a strength in that.
Yeah.
If you're looking at it correctly.
I think this self-awareness that comes to like,
I know where I flourish.
I know what I like.
And that's the editing function-
We also sorry to interrupt.
No, that's okay.
Making sure that is coming
from a higher consciousness state rather than
an outgrowth of your fixed mindset at that time.
Yes.
About your capabilities.
Yeah, it's having that openness again to the intuition,
to the wisdom, to something that actually may emerge
that is not scripted for you.
And that's actually, frankly why in the great resignation
in the pandemic,
we've seen an enormous explosion in people 45 and older
going out and starting their own business.
Yeah and a lot of young people not going back to the job.
And a lot of young people not going back to the job
and that's-
And confusion like what?
Like people are confused that's-
That's right.
But what I find interesting on the 45 year olds and up
is we tend to think about like all the entrepreneurs,
like the hot entrepreneurs are under 30.
But the fastest growing set of entrepreneurs
in the country today are 45 and older.
Is that right?
Yeah exactly.
And so over 50% of the businesses,
the new businesses started in the US
are people 50 and older.
Yeah, I love that idea of attunement.
Like in retrospect, reflecting back on my life,
like so much of everything that I'm so blessed
to be able to do now,
has been a process of trying to focus on attunement,
having that kind of crisis with what I was doing
relatively early.
Like everybody thinks of 40 as like this pivotal
kind of life crisis.
And now it just feels cute.
Like at 55, like 40, you were so young.
And kind of in elegantly,
but eventually fall into this vocation
that I feel like meets my skill sets,
allows me to continue to develop this growth mindset,
and is successful only to the extent
to which I can be attuned with you.
Yeah.
Like I can't achieve this conversation
for it to be valuable or successful
for the person who's listening to it.
That is truly a function of the extent
to which I can be prepared, but yet completely present,
and in the allowing.
So the opposite of presence is absence.
And we live in an absent culture,
partly because we have all have an iPhone in our hand.
And when you meet someone who has presence,
whether it's a mentor, whether it's a teacher,
whether it's a friend, whether it's a romantic partner,
when they are present in the moment you notice it.
And this is a quality we get better at as we age,
I make actually, we're very present when we're young.
So we're very present.
You see that a child,
a two year old, or a one year old,
sort of just looking at things and there's a presence there.
And then we accumulate knowledge as we get older
and in our childhood
and we have scripts that we're living
and we're less present.
And there's a point at which we become present again,
I happen to think it's around when the operating system
of the soul kicks in.
And when we start to become present again,
things come through us.
So most of my life, I can do it personally, can do it.
We had 3,500 employees at Joie de Vivre
and I handed out 3,500 copies of the book,
"The Little Engine That Could."
Do you remember that (indistinct).
Of course, yes.
So the childhood story of this tiny little not caboose,
but the train at the start of the...
What would you call the first train?
I don't know.
The engine.
The engine thank you.
That's a little engine that could, thank you Rich (laughs).
I know this story.
It's so imprinted into my childhood.
So the little engine that could was sort of brought
into duty to do something that was beyond what it thought
it could do.
And bring all those animals,
the circus or zoo animals up a mountain.
So the conduit attitude was very much in my brain
and it was like something I wanted all of my employees
to have.
And we saw that in terms of guest loyalty,
a guest who felt that the employees
had a can do it attitude,
that was the number one correlation
with whether the guest would be loyal.
Can do it, can do it, can do it.
I have moved from can it to conduit.
So conduit is attainment, can do it is I can do it.
Can do it, is rugged individualism.
It is the ego run riot,
and it has wonderful qualities about it.
But there's a point at which can do it
when it can shift to conduit.
What happens is you're now the channel,
you are the present one who's channeling something
through you.
And whether this...
If Julie was here right now,
we'd get into a very deep spiritual conversation about this.
But it is your ability to be the channel
the conduit of things through you.
And when you get to that state,
there's a power that you are conducting,
that is so much greater than anything you can do
in the conduit stage.
And all of this sounds very ethereal,
but you know it when you see it and you feel it.
Sort of like pornography (chuckles).
Definition of pornography from the Supreme Court
was you know it when you see it.
Presence and someone's power as a conduit,
you know it when you see it.
And I guess I would just say that
it's that level of energy.
Someone said to me you've written a book Chip
about wisdom at work,
and all these older people are gonna come to you
and say, how can I get a job in my 50s, or my 40s or my 60s?
And this executive recruiter said something
that was so beautiful and it relates to this.
She said "If you show up with curiosity
"and passionate engagement in your interview,
"whether it's in Zoom or in person,
"what people will notice is not your wrinkles,
"but they'll notice your energy.
"And when they notice your energy,
"they lose track of your age."
And that is so true.
I mean, I'm feeling it right now, as I'm speaking to you,
you're feeling it from me probably.
Yeah it's really powerful.
There's an energy, and when someone is...
And energy is something that's coming through you,
it's not just how much weight you're lifting.
But it could be.
I mean, the conduit can come through you
in all kinds of ways.
But for me, it comes through me
in this role as a teacher now, but also a learner.
And I love being in an environment where I can look back
and say, I lost five friends to suicide
between 2008 and 2010.
I wish there had been a midlife wisdom school
and a place where they could have done a great midlife edit
such that they could still be on the planet.
And that's, what's coming through me.
Yeah, the conduit.
There's something really beautiful about that.
That also I've just noticed when I can inhabit that space,
to the extent that I'm capable,
that is so much more fulfilling
than the striving and the accumulating.
Yeah.
To be this channel for somebody else's success,
or to be the connective tissue between two things
that then become greater than the sum of their parts.
Yeah.
There's a guy named Eric Erickson,
developmental psychologist.
And he said five words
that just to me define this era of life,
he said, "I am what survives me."
And that really means a lot because
it suggests that we've moved to an era of your life
where generativity is the key.
And he also said in our midlife and later years,
the challenges between generativity and stagnation.
But generativity is different than attainment.
Generativity means you're creatively generating things,
but it's for other people.
It often he meant it in the term of generations
for other generations.
So how do we co-generate?
How do we create things that are gonna survive us,
that are gonna support other people
and help them be a better version of themselves
and maybe a better version of me.
I mean, through them.
So yeah, I mean...
Again, this is very much the mentorship language,
but I think one of the things
that people need to think about as they get older
is their legacy.
And not the legacy, the ego legacy.
It's not so much,
how am I going to be remembered that's important,
but that has a certain ego attached.
It's more how will I have served?
And when the shift can go to, how have I served,
there's something in it that speaks to, what am I doing?
That's gonna live beyond me.
That is gonna have an influence way beyond me sitting here.
Yeah.
Well, I think that's a good place
to kind of lead into the last thing,
that I want to talk to you about.
Which is for that person who is contemplating
all of this right now,
perhaps they're in their 40s or their 50s.
And they're thinking about what's next,
or if there is even going to be anything next.
And maybe doesn't have that level
of self understanding or self integration
to really have the intuition
to follow wherever they're being led by their curiosity.
And perhaps they don't have the budget
to go down to Baja and participate in your academy.
What are some things that they could be thinking about,
perhaps books they could be reading
or ways of approaching that level of self inquiry
that could help unlock some of those answers.
Lots of great books out there.
"Wisdom at Work."
"Wisdom at Work," being one of them.
But "The 100-Year Life" is a really interesting book
written by two UK academics talking about the medical world
says that children being born today,
there's a 50% chance they're gonna live to 100.
So how would you curate your life differently
if you knew you were gonna live 'til 100?
So it's a great book.
There's gosh, what other books do I love?
Let me just...
When you mention that something comes to mind,
which is another tension.
The tension between yes, let's contemplate our lives at 100
and how we can plan for that.
But how do you like sort of reconcile that
with another powerful idea,
which is what if you don't have?
What if you only have three months or six months
or a year to live?
How would that change how you're approaching
the way that you spend your time?
Well, that's a very different question.
So I'm gonna come back to that one.
Well, I'll go to that one now.
So Laura Carstensen, I'm on her advisory board
at the Stanford Center on longevity,
and she's done very conclusive research
on this to show that the shorter period of time you have
in your life,
the more you take seriously each moment.
It makes sense.
And she looked at it with older people,
but also people who had aids,
people who had a cancer diagnosis that was incurable.
And what they found was that when you have less time,
you are more mindful in the moment.
And that makes sense.
You're less focused on the past.
You're less focused on the future.
You're more focused on the moment.
And what comes from that
is a certain level of life satisfaction and contentment.
And so that is...
I would just say for anybody who's looking at their life
right now and saying,
"I don't feel very content."
My response to them would be,
how much are you spending time in the moment?
How can you do that?
Yes, you can meditate.
Yes you can do yoga.
Go for a walk with your dog in nature.
So during the pandemic,
when I was living in Baja and we had no guests
because we had to shut down.
I would do...
I'd put on my calendar three hours a day, three days a week.
And I called it spying on the divine.
And I would go get divinely intoxicated in nature.
And I don't mean I brought alcohol or psychedelics, no.
I was going for a walk with my dog for three hours
in different, natural, beautiful places around Baja.
And just noticing what nature could teach me.
The resilience of nature, the interdependence of nature.
I was being in the moment.
And our friend Dr. Ketner,
who started the greater good science center at UC Berkeley
and is on our faculty and has a book coming out next year.
Talks about the various forms of how you can find awe
in your life.
And for so many people it's found in nature.
So I'd say that is something you can do.
You've gotta park near you.
You don't have to spend any money on that.
You don't have to buy a book for that.
But there's lots of other good books.
There's "From Strength To Strength" that just came out
with Arthur Brook.
There's Becca Levy's book "Breaking the Age Code."
Becca Levy is the one who actually...
In many ways our program is built on her work from Yale.
She was able to show that when you shift a person
from a negative to a neutral mindset.
I'm sorry, from a negative to a positive mindset on aging,
you give them 7.5 additional years of life.
What?
It's actually more life
than if someone stopped smoking at age 50,
or if they started exercising at age 50.
So the public health benefit of shifting a mindset
around aging has a greater benefit to society
and people are happier.
And yet we have PSAs left and right
about how we should stop smoking,
and how we should start exercising.
We have no PSAs around how to reframe aging.
So her book "Breaking the Age Code,"
which just came out in the last month is a great book.
You could do, I mean online.
I mean, our purpose course starts in June.
And that is not very expensive and it's eight week course.
But there's lots of ways that for people
to actually ask themselves.
My blog, my daily blog is free "Wisdom Well."
It's really sort of the best of MEA curriculum.
Get a micro dose of wisdom every morning.
Yeah.
And maybe adopt that weekly inventory journaling process.
Oh yes.
My wisdom book.
Exactly.
Yeah.
Beautiful man.
Thank you.
Really inspiring to talk to you.
Yeah.
I want to come down and visit Baja.
Yeah, maybe we could co-lead a week.
That would be great.
Yeah.
I would love that.
I need more Chip Conley in my life.
(Chip laughs)
If I need more Rich Roll (indistinct) yes.
Well, you're helpful for me
because it's funny last quick thought.
I'm not vegan, but I started a vegan restaurant.
That's right.
We didn't even talk about that.
Like I had no idea
that you were co millennium of millennium.
Yeah, no, I started-
That's just a legendary...
I thought Robin Williams owned it at some point.
No, no, no.
Robin Williams (indistinct)-
He used to there a lot.
He went to a lot, (indistinct) went a lot.
A lot of people went there.
By the way, have you seen the movie, the show, "Bad Vegan."
Yes, that's a whole other podcast.
Oh my god.
I used to go there.
(indistinct) pure food all the time.
I did too.
So long story short you are a reminder for me
because of your show and your presence
about me taking care of my body.
Good.
Because I had prostate cancer and I am-
That's right (indistinct) how are you doing?
I had a surgery, that I only have half of prostate now,
but my PSA is below one and it was 10.8.
Yeah that's good.
Life is a lot better and you're that reminder
of take care of myself.
All right, well, if I could be so audacious,
I will consider this the first installment
in an ongoing conversation.
Beautiful.
I'd love to have you back.
Thank you.
So thank Chip.
Appreciate you.
Peace.
(upbeat music)